since we're talking about manipulating
data let's talk a little bit about the
built in object called math math this is
an example math background has a lot of
built-in properties and methods that are
going to help you manipulate any
numerical data that you're working with
just like with the other methods you
don't have to memorize them all but you
should really look at the Mozilla
developer Network page to see what math
has to offer a good example that I like
to use with math is math dot random
which I used in my zip line for the
quote generator there's something else
that you should know about working with
numbers that doesn't have to do with
math there's something called
floating-point format that JavaScript
uses what I'm telling you this is later
when you're doing a lot of calculations
depending on the calculations how large
the numbers are how many calculations
you're doing there might be a little bit
of an accuracy like four or five decimal
points down the line there are ways to
get around this and it's not that big of
a deal
but I'm telling you this so if you're
ever getting an error or there's some
number it just isn't adding up right
it's not your fault that's built into
the language and there are plenty of
ways around it